oh boy nascar racing rolls into las  vegas this weekend  sunday's pennzoil 400 is already sold  out but there are tickets for the races  on friday and saturday available  about 12 000 fans are allowed at the  speedway this year because of health  district rules because of the pandemic  star driver joey logano says even with  fewer fans they can still make an impact  when he's in the wheat in the car  but as a competitor yeah you can  definitely tell  um for me and where us as drivers notice  at the most  beginning of the race you know before  you get in the car driver intros  yelling screaming the boom the cheering  all that um you know  you have that which is you know great  and and you can use that to motivate you  to fire up for the race  you know as many fans there as possible  that energy radiates through  you know the whole the whole racetrack  logano won the last  two spring races here in las vegas